sommes en direct avec frédéric à la
visart économiste de la santé
auteur de et alors la réforme globale de
la santé c'est pour quand aux éditions
fauves grand prix on le précise du
meilleur livre de l'économie de l'année
2020 à ses côtés fabrice di vizio
avocats des professions de santé plus
particulièrement du collectif c 19 à
l'origine de de plusieurs plaintes
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
conclure les négociations du ségur cette
semaine est ce que cela vous semble
possible
frédéric bizarre tu es tout tout est
possible maintenant d'abord il ya un
diagnostic est assez partagée c'est que
la crise de l'hôpital public est une
crise du système de santé et n'est pas
réductible à un problème de rémunération
donc même si dans le dans le meilleur
des scénarios on arrive à conclure un
accord ce qui juge ce qui évidemment est
possible à partir du moment où vous êtes
capable de mettre des milliards
quasiment sans limites et surtout des
milliards qui ne sont pas financés
puisque les étaient similaires ces sept
milliards 3 maintenant et on ne sait
toujours pas comment est-ce qu'on va les
financer puisque la sécurité sociale
c'est pas l'état cyclos de sel peut pas
s'endetter indéfiniment c'est pas c'est
pas de l'investissement sur des charges
courantes que vous amenez donc il faut
que les français sachent s'ils savaient
peut-être de la csg en plus si les
charges sociales en plus mais forcément
il y aura 7 milliards 300 millions ce
soir de charges supplémentaires à
financer par les charges sociales ou la
csg de jeu donc va peut-être qu'on peut
trouver un accord si on n'a pas de
limite dans la hausse des charges
mais encore une fois ça ne réglera rien
au problème de l'hôpital public qui qui
qui a un chef dean attractivité depuis
des années bon du fait d'un certain
nombre de réformes qui ont été faites
peut-être qu'on y reviendra donc
donc si c'est une si c'est un accord
dans la semaine comme le veut le premier
ministre de toute façon ce ne peut être
qu'un accord de cours de courte durée
fabrice di vizio on va surtout parler
avec vous des fameuses plantes mai
voyez opiné de la tête c'est vrai que
vous connaissez aussi ces dossiers
puisque vous les connaissez vin bien ces
soignants vous représentez il ya eu
cette annonce effectivement ce soir de
jean castex qui veut conclure rapidement
les choses et annonce donc mettre 7
milliards d'euros sur la table alors que
les syndicats en veulent lui tond se
rapproche tout de même de ce que
souhaitent les soignants à ce qu'il ya
une chance pour vous justement que ça
aboutisse et que cela satisfasse ces
soignants justement ce soir voyez vous
je crois que mon mal très français c'est
qu'on pense qu'en alignant des milliards
ont réglé des problèmes
le problème c'est que souvent en
alignant des milliards des manières j'ai
envie de dire complètement
inconditionnel et manière comme ça
finalement sur la table eh ben on ajoute
des problèmes je dis pas qu'à pas un
problème de rémunération à l'hôpital
jeudi que limiter le problème de
l'hôpital à la rémunération c'est
extrêmement réducteur et qu'on aurait pu
attendre de ces secteurs de la santé
qu'ils se saisissent vraiment du
problème j'avais dit au départ que rien
n'aboutit lettres ségur et à la sortie
du ségur je consulte partager cet avis
non pas que les rémunérations le coup de
pouce aurait duration ne soit pas un
problème mais d'abord répondu du
financement effectivement mais deux on
est passé à côté des vrais problèmes
on est passé à côté de quel hôpital on
veut on est passé à côté de quelques
opérations entre la ville et l'hôpital
on est passé à côté des vrais enjeux
stratégiques de santé qu'on a révélé ce
qu vide en fait ce qu vie n'était pas
seulement un problème de rémunération de
l'hôpital n'était bien autre chose tout
autre chose en fait le problème c'est
que comme on a un enjeu de communication
est un enjeu politique encore il fallait
faire les choses vite et d'étaler donc
les faire mal c'est tout frédéric
bizarre tout de même en fait pas prendre
la défense du gouvernement je suis pas
là pour ça mais je suis là pourront
effectivement poser des questions et
apporter la contradiction ce que vient
nous dire fabrice di vizio c'est
intéressant parce que voilà fallait
faire vite mais en même temps les
soignants demandent eux justement des
augmentations c'est très légitime de
leur part demande une augmentation des
lits et c'est vrai qu'une réforme
structurelle de l'hôpital par définition
brand prend beaucoup plus de temps alors
comment allier ccl2 équilibre
correctement sinon de l'eau
ambition c'est plutôt constructif
giclait l'institut santé il ya deux ans
on a créé un centre de recherche dédié à
la refondation on essaie d'apporter
chacun notre pierre à l'édifice parce
que la refonte du système de santé
absolument indispensable puisque l'on
vit sur un système qui a été créée il ya
soixante dix ans donc il n'y a
absolument plus à jour alors qu'on a
parmi les meilleurs soignants monde on
allait à toutes les ressources qu'il
faut donc on est dans un énorme gâchis
le sentiment aujourd'hui que notre
système de santé défaillant et quand
même le signe d'un énorme gâchis dont il
faut avoir conscience je pense donc moi
je je je je je m'active pour essayer de
participer à cette refondation
la déception que le aujourd'hui mois de
la déclaration du premier ministre
c'est qu'ils semblent lui véritablement
penser que le problème est un problème
uniquement de rémunération et qu'il
suffit de le régler rapidement pour que
l'on puisse passer à un autre dossier
non le dossier de la santé c'est le
dossier du prochain quinquennat
c'est le dossier qui va prendre des
années parce que c'est un c'est un
système qu'il faut remettre sur pied
pour les 50 ans à venir maintenant vous
avez raison il ya un problème de court
terme qui est un problème plus politique
politiciens qu'un problème est aussi
kiki qui est lié au système de santé
puisque on a vu que l'hôpital ça a été
dit par fabrice di vizio de façon tout à
fait juste on a vu que s'il ya quelque
chose qui a bien tenu pendant cette
crise du coc vite c'est l'hôpital alors
que le reste n'a pas tenu parce que la
vraie crise du système de santé n'est
pas l'hôpital
elle est par une défaillance totale de
la prise en amont du risque maladie ce
qu'on appelle la prévention ce qu'on
appelle les déterminants de santé une
médecine de ville qui est un train
véritablement de se désintégrer avec des
unes avec des territoires qui sont sens
en médecine de ville à un système médico
social qui est quand même à l'agonie
c'est là la vraie crise c'est pas un
hôpital public
l'hôpital public un problème de
reconnaissance du personnel soignant
mais croyez moi la vraie crise n'est pas
à l'hôpital public donc de laisser
entendre que havre ajoutant 7 milliards
d'euros
on va entre guillemets régler le
problème du système de santé
là c'est quelque chose qui est tellement
loin de la réalité quels que soient les
sensibilités qu'on peut avoir quelle que
soit la mémé ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement partager
parmi toutes les sensibilités politiques
donc moi c'est ça ne que le politique
monsieur le président arrive le monsieur
présent la république monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur nice de la
santé surtout surtout ne pas faire
croire en français on va régler la
question du système de santé avec sept
ou huit milliards d'euros a pour
l'hôpital public
fabrice di vizio le maintien de
d'olivier véran à son passé c'est plutôt
un bon signal qui va dans le bon sens on
les personnels moi j'ai un problème avec
le maintien d'olivier verrons j'ai un
problème je suis si vous voulez d'abord
il ya la présomption d'innocence votre
vivant il fait l'objet de pressions
judiciaires
mais je pense qu'à un moment si vous
voulez moi ce qui me perturbe et olivier
ferrand c'est que il est sous le coup
d'une information judiciaire qui quand
même touche à l'exercice même de sa
mission dans le cadre d'une épidémie
alors qu'il était en poste et il a eu
des déclarations pour le moins
malheureuse qui ont été relevées par les
médecins libéraux
et donc quand même je peux
raisonnablement m'interroger de savoir
si le poste de ministre de la santé ne
méritait pas mieux
dans un temps de reconstruction
précisément que finalement olivier
derand qui aujourd'hui est quand même
sous le coup d'une information
judiciaire
c'est quand un ministre en exercice avec
un réducteur
une mission normalement cadre fondation
de l'hôpital si une deuxième bague
arrive il va être effectivement au
premier large
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la
bonne personne pour assumer ce rôle à
titre personnel je pense que non parce
que je pense que nous sommes une société
de symboles et que qui plus est à
presque vide et que symboliquement avoir
un ministre de la santé qui est sous le
coup d'une information judiciaire pour
effectivement sa gestion de la crise
c'est quand même un problème à mes yeux
c'est un vrai problème et il est allé
très loin olivier derand quand il dit
que les cabinets libéraux ont fermé dans
coguic c'est la raison pour laquelle
notamment ils n'ont pas une masse il va
- il va très très loin et dans ce
contexte on a un ministre qui n'a
toujours pas produit les bons de
commande de masques
donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui est inédite et pour moi je
pense que l'apaisement social méritait
quand même en toute quiétude comme à ce
poste si vous voulez peut pas à la fois
dans des jean castex premier ministre
olivier ferrand mise de la santé
gardez votre miros bachelot mise à la
culture sans qu'à un moment donné on se
dise légitimement médias le gâteau
qu'est ce que les soignants ont donc
fait à ce gouvernement
frédéric bizarre sur ces nouvelles
nominations ça peut porter préjudice aux
figures de la de la santé ont finalement
c'est une bonne chose pour le ségur de
la santé c'est un sens de conserver un
ministre qui a démarré les négociations
donc moi ça ça me choque pas mais
maintenant ce que ce qui serait
souhaitable c'est qu'heuliez verrons qui
a été rapporteur des différents projets
de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale de ces dernières années donc qui
a été co constructeur de la politique de
santé depuis ces dernières années et
prennent conscience que il faut vraiment
prendre un virage mais pas un virage
idéologique
c'est un virage parce que le monde a
tellement changé sur le plan
épidémiologique sur le plan
démographique sur le plan technologique
que notre système qui a été excellent
sur le plan du soin au xxème siècle
devienne un système excellent 21e siècle
et pour ça il faut le transformer il
faut passer du soin la santé c'est à
dire qu'il faut enfin reconnaître que
les personnes bien portantes sont aussi
importantes que les personnes malades le
système attend que les gens soient
valables pour les prendre en charge
on est tout à fait dans un système qui
était qui est archaïque qui est très bon
dans son archaïsme quand les gens sont
malades mais ça ne suffit plus
aujourd'hui du fait du changement
d'environnement il faut on a en étouffer
la démocratie sanitaire ont déjà un
système qui a totalement du rock rate is
et qu'ils aient décidé de l'avenue de
ségur alors qu'ils font un système qui
partent des territoires qui partent des
besoins de santé sont des choses quand
même content qu'on rabâche que l'on
connaît dont on connaît les solutions et
de ce point de vue c'est vrai que je
n'entends jamais olivier ferrand dire il
va falloir qu'on fasse différemment de
ce qu'on a fait ces 20 dernières années
ils sont dans une continuité qui est
quand même une continuité dans le déclin
du système
si on ne change pas vérité
le monde la proche et l'état d'esprit
par rapport au système de santé qu'il
faudrait mettre en place fabrice
division vous ont parlé tout à l'heure
de cette enquête judiciaire évidemment
ouverte par la cjr contre olivier
ferrand vous l'avez dit agnès buzyn
également edouard philippe neuf plaintes
recevables sur les 90 reçu par la cour
de justice de la république c'est beau
c'est beaucoup comment vous jugez ce
chiffre bas je peux pas le juger je sais
pas ce que contenaient les les autres
plaintes pour le coup ce que je sais
c'est que apparemment un certain nombre
de toute façon pas recevable parce que
le formalisme est assez exigeant en
outre je pense que n'ont été retenus si
j'ai bien compris que les plaintes qui
vise l article 223 7 du code pénal c'est
à dire l'omission volontaire en fait
l'abstention volontaire et donc toutes
les attractions dont un intentionnel ont
été considérés comme n'étant pas
recevable du coup forcément ça limitait
considérablement le nombre de plaintes
mais ceci dit ce n'est pas très étonnant
si vous voulez c'est à dire que on
savait aussi je l'avais d'ailleurs dit
un que sur ces quatre à quatre plaintes
y en avait beaucoup qui était la
manifestation d'une colère la
manifestation impulsif colère mais tu ne
correspondait pas à une démarche
juridique construite et à mon sens les
celle qui correspond à une démarche
juridique construites ont été admises
dès lors le fondement a été bon que les
faits étaient bons et donc c'est
légitime si vous voulez je ne suis pas
surpris outre mesure combien de neuf
plaintes 84 ça dépend vraiment et il
semblait que procureur général semblait
dire d'ailleurs que beaucoup émanait de
particulier sans avocat par exemple donc
le formalisme ne serait-ce que ça
n'était pas respecté merci à tous les
deux frédéric bizarre fabrice sa
division d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage merci à tous les deux